بتاع الرئيس الفرنسي ايمانويل ماكرون الى
منح روسيا ضمانات امنيه اذا عادت للتفاوض
احدى النقاط الاساسيه التي طالما شدد
عليها بوتين هي الخشيه من ان ياتي حلف
الناتو الى بوابات روسيا هذا الموضوع
سيكون جزءا من المواضيع المتعلقه باحلال
السلام وبالتالي وجب التحضير لما نحن
مستعدون لفعله وكيف سنحمله والدول الاعضاء
عبر اعطاء ضمانات لروسيا تتعلق بامنها حين
تعود الى طاوله المفاوضات
واقل مكرونه ستواصلوا دعم اوكرانيا عسكريا
وانها ستزودك بمزيد من الاسلحه واوضح ان
هذا الدعم لن يشمل اي معدات عسكريه تمكن
اوكرانيا من مهاجمه الاراضي الروسيه بما
يقتحموا فرنسا
ساحاول انا واضح الامر منذ بدايه النزاع
قررنا فعلا تقديم الدعم العسكري وهناك
دوما خطان لتحديد اجراءاتنا بطريقه بسيطه
جدا لن نضعف ابدا قدره جيوشنا على حمايه
اراضينا وجنودنا ومواطنين ابدا والحدث
الثاني هو اننا لن نسلم ابدا اسلحه يمكنها
ان تورطنا في الصراع اي تسمح بمهاجمه
روسيا على ارضها قمنا ونستمر في القيام
بما هو في استطاعتنا اذا الاجابه هي نعم
سنسلم اسلحه اضافيه وسنطلب من مصانعنا
تسريع وتيره الانتاج لتسليم طلبات
العسكريه الاوكرانيه في ضوء امامك